hi I'm Erik Bosse and captain Marvel's
new trailer opened up some very
interesting questions about this movie's
plot at the top of this list is everyone
who they say they are the stuff from
Captain Marvel that we've seen so far is
focused largely on this whole idea of
memories fractured memories potentially
false implanted memories with this
movie's apparent villains the alien race
the squirrel having the power of
shape-shifting literally they can pose
as good guys in plain sight like sweet
old ladies on trains or a high-ranking
agent and shield like Talos this recent
trailer opened with a very bold
declaration so scrolls are the bad guys
why does that totally true could it be a
misdirection well I'm gonna dig into
this question and spoiler warning in
case any my theories end up being right
okay while we're watching the recent
Captain Marvel trailer for my in-depth
breakdown which you should definitely
check out if you haven't already the
first red flag that caught my attention
was the definitive line in the sand that
Carol Danvers returned to Earth after
her time super soldiering for the Kree
Empire draws between the warring alien
races a race of noble boys heroes noble
warrior heroes her confidence in
absolutism should be alarming to you
like rule number one for superheroes
when someone calls you a hero and not
the hero firefighters in the teeth
running around they're the real heroes
and later in the trailer there was the
tone with which Annette benning's
character some Creely der explains to
Carol how she came to join their empires
found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior okay another good rule
to live by never refer to your own kind
as superior just get that thought out of
your head you're not and if someone
proudly tells you we're superior and
you're one of us turn around and run
there's already been some speculation
that judwaa is still not officially
named creased our commander character is
actually the Kree villain from the
Marvel Comics jaan raghav Uncle pop
young rock that some say kind of looks
like Jude Law because Jude Law's of
course three inches tall and plastic in
my breakdown you can see all the
evidence that I laid out for Carroll's
memories of her super-powered origin
actually being false memories implanted
in her mind by the Kree perhaps to
brainwash her into a scroll killing
super soldier fighting for the Kree
Empire all of the stuff leads need to
predict that the Kree are probably not
the noble warrior heroes that Carol so
bluntly brags about Nick Fury it's just
such a narrow-minded absolute that the
movies gonna have to overturn if we want
Captain Marvel to be a hero whom we
relate with the Kree is a militaristic
Empire who will do anything to wipe out
their enemies to scroll in the galactic
storm comics the Kree have a reputation
for being super EXTREME the Kree supreme
intelligence actually commits genocide
upon their own Kriya race all in order
to have force the survivors to evolve
and break past their genetic stagnation
there's got to be a better way for that
now in the comics the scroll are pretty
evil too they're usually depicted as
even worse than the Kree
due to the way their shape-shifting
abilities manifest into deception like
in The Secret Invasion storyline the
Marvel comics we learn that for years
the scroll and actually infiltrated the
ranks of human society including the
Avengers everyone loses it now this
Captain Marvel movie appears to be
hinting at the villainous Secret
Invasion by the scroll as well like Ben
Mendelsohn is playing Talos a scroll
leader who has posed as a SHIELD agent
and Mendelsohn has only really played
villains ready player one rogue one The
Dark Knight Rises that Netflix series
bloodline it's really his thing he's
great at it
in this recent trailer we actually hear
Talos speak would you like to
what you really are locked yeah I'm like
me Mendelssohn actually is Australian
but really this is the first time I can
remember him using his native accent in
a major role maybe I'm overthinking it
but I'm wondering if the reason is
because this Captain Marvel movie what's
something deeper than the staging
theatrical baddies at Mendelssohn
normally plays a more nuanced role
requiring Mendelssohn to tap into his
more natural humanity whether or not you
agree about the accent I get it it could
be stretching it I think this trailer is
I did some clues about the scrolls true
agenda like there's that one shot with
Carole upside down temples getting
zapped with the scroll appearing beside
her in the white frame or the scroll
torturing her well she doesn't really
appear to be in much pain here maybe
they're extracting memory fragments from
her to help her piece together her past
which is her main goal in this movie
also there was that shot that I pointed
out in the breakdown heralds crash site
memory where she sees a figure
approaching her through the smoke
one shot reveals the figure to be a
scroll but a different angle this moment
from earlier in the trailer from outside
Carole's point of view shows someone
wearing green Kree armor does this mean
the Kree intelligence and planted a
false memory and took Harold's mind to
turn this Kree soldier that she saw into
a villainous squirrel attacking her so
that she'd be brainwashed into thinking
all scroll are murderers and then be a
more effective killing machine against
girls
maybe we should let's to say that this
doesn't mean the scroll are all innocent
victims like they're a war hungry Empire
just like the Kree are but rather than
drink this kool-aid of one side being
noble warrior heroes and the other side
being absolute bad guys we should be
open to the scroll having different
intentions like if it all just ends up
being at the scroll invaded Earth's
government agency is to destabilize and
take over them fine but didn't we
already see a version of that with Hydra
and Captain America Winter Soldier it's
been done in the MCU just a couple years
ago
so imagine alternate scroll objectives
like what if their goal was to simply
infiltrate the ranks of shields and
other security forces to better protect
Earth from a Kree invasion like rather
than an evil network of terrorists they
could just be rebel freedom fighters
hiding in plain sight trying to make the
universe a better place you know in pop
culture we have seen another conspiracy
that crept its
antek government positions to manipulate
innocent pawns in a chess game against a
noble Empire yeah the KGB spies to the
Americans
just kidding kind of of course I'm
referring to the Rebel Alliance of Star
Wars
remember Bail Organa was one of many who
had to play both sides in public an
independent senator who secretly
supported a terrorist network
Talos could be a similar figure a
clandestine agent and a powerful
government position working hard to keep
the dangerous Empire and its Imperial
Stormtroopers are away from here in this
case one of those stormtroopers in fact
the best of them happens to break away
and rediscover her humanity hey this
kind of like Finn it's all connected I'm
just saying do not be surprised if
Captain Marvel features a twist where
the scroll suddenly looked more like the
noble warrior heroes of this conflict
ultimately it appears that Captain
Marvel has no interest in fighting for
either side of this war like she just
wants to end it like I could see both
sides having committed war crimes and
atrocities that Carroll objects to so
she's like you both suck stay away from
my planet but little bit but my question
for you is which character do you think
will be the most evil villain of this
Captain Marvel movie Talos Jude Law's
character an epinions character Ronin
that cat we got another video about that
in the works coming down below with your
thoughts so then following new rock
stars on Twitter at new rock stars in me
on twitter and instagram @ ee vos it
subscribed new rock stars more deep
theories about Marvel the Avengers Star
Wars all kinds of details that you're
gonna want to know about know about now
know I know I nailed it
[Music]